das ist so ein angeborener herzfehler
ich möchte das nicht jetzt übertreiben
aber ich denke 1 zu 400.000 der post
coburger einmal komplett auf geschnitten
weil wir so einen kleinen menschen kommt
man ja schlechter dran haben wir etwas
übersehen haben wir das ging nicht
richtig vorbereitet oder habe ich der
zeitpunkt nicht richtig gewählt oder
habe ich so einen technischen fehler
gemacht
im op saal so alles zu durchzuführen
nicht hundertprozentig sicher zu sein so
dass er das ist meine motivation
[Musik]
manchmal ist die belastung so groß dass
das herz und patient das nicht
verkraftet und man verliert pazifik
[Musik]
und machen sie das 34 jahre dann
schaffen sie die marke 10.000 10.000